hello everyone it is
scp-049 again
back playing certain simulator
as you can see i've been practicing
quite a lot and earned myself a
certificate
not in my name but
oh well what can you do
now today i'm going to be doing
something a little bit different with
this vcr tape now
all i have to do
is lift it up and
put it in
put it in
four
nine
four
eight
now this will become obvious as to why
those numbers flashed up on the screen
here we have
a numerical pad
and if i
enter 4948
[Music]
this will happen
it appears to be
a grey
a grey alien something you would see in
roswell
or area 51
that's a myth by the way
it doesn't exist now as with all
rib surgeries the bone sore
or the circular bone saw i'm not really
sure
as to the exact terminology this
technology
really is
uh
way beyond anything i could imagine
but this is the best to use for any rib
surgery now if i
just get rid of that
i
need to remove
all bone
from this carcass
because otherwise it would
make the surgery absolutely impossible
the left side
seems to be
maybe a little bit of trouble i'm sorry
that
oh
my
okay
so just leave this here anti-gravity can
be handy sometimes
it's not always
an annoyance
now this thing
seems to have no purpose whatsoever
so i'm just going to throw this away
now i think now i need a scalpel
oh it appears
that worked i didn't expect that to work
now i believe
the center organ
of this gray
is called a gobble shaft
it's not a very
[Music]
sores can be troublesome
anyway this
is called a gobble shaft now it's not a
very eloquent name
i don't know
anyway
i'm not really sure what it does
[Music]
but no matter it's coming out anyway
rather
rather peculiar noise
that thing makes
very strange
right
now
i'm going to need to remove the six blue
membranes on the left
and on the right
i can just position my knife
or scalpel in such a way
and that's done
at the bottom
and the top
of the burger sporax organ
again i'm not sure has to its purpose
but
if i was to make an estimation i would
say
would say it's probably
the stomach or the digestive system
this is proving quite
never mind
with enough force you can make anything
happen
okay
i'm not quite sure
i think
the organ on the top right
is called
sorry i was just concentrating that i
think the organ in the top right is
called the gavitro
and it appears i have just
poisoned myself
on one of their spikes
very peculiar noise
so if i could just
make an incision
on the left of the cavity
i'm not
really sure this is essential to the
replacement of the burgess bormack spot
i've started now i might as well finish
this is proving extremely difficult
i'm clearly
i'm clearly scraping my scalpel over it
i'm not sure what i'm doing wrong
okay well
i may
need to use something else over to the
left earth yes
scalpel
i may need to be quite heavy-handed this
time as
going in delicately doesn't seem to be
doing me any favors at all
yes that seems to have worked
good
okay all i have to do is throw this
scalpel away
take the gevature out
completely an unnecessary part of this
but it is extraterrestrial surgery so
there is always a learning curve
my fingers almost got stuck in that jar
if i
never mind i was going to use the hammer
that just fell out of my hands apologies
so break this
i should have thrown that away but never
mind
this is the fresh burgess borax
[Music]
or sporex i'm not sure
put it in there
and there you have it
this is how you transplant a burger
sporax
i hope you've all enjoyed this
and until next time
i am the cure
you